[Music]
on May 27 1941 the German battleship
Bismarck sank in a fierce firefight
leaving only a hundred and eighteen of
her 2200 crew members alive but when a
British destroyer came to collect the
prisoners they found an unexpected
survivor a black and white cat clinging
to a floating plank for the next several
months this cat hunted rats and raised
British morale until a sudden torpedo
strike shattered the hull and sank the
ship but miraculously not the cat
nicknamed unsinkable Sam he rowed to
Gibraltar with the rescued crew and
served as a ship cat on three more
vessels one of which also sank before
retiring to the Belfast home for sailors
many may not think of cats as
serviceable sailors all cooperative
companions of any kind but cats have
been working alongside humans for
thousands of years helping us just as
often as we helped them so how did these
solitary creatures go from wild predator
to naval officer to sofa sidekick the
domestication of the modern house cat
can be traced back to more than ten
thousand years ago in the Fertile
Crescent at the start of the Neolithic
era people were learning to bend nature
to their will producing much more food
than farmers could eat at one time these
Neolithic farmers stored their excess
grain in large pits and short clay silos
but these stores of food attracted
hordes of rodents as well as their
predator felice Silvestre SLIB occur the
wild cat found across North Africa and
Southwest Asia these wild cats were fast
fierce carnivorous hunters and they were
remarkably similar in size and
appearance to today's domestic cats the
main differences being that ancient
Wildcats were more muscular had striped
copes and were less social towards other
cats and humans the abundance of prey in
rodent infested greeneries threw in
these typically solitary animals and as
the Wildcats learned to tolerate the
presence of humans and other cats during
mealtime we think that farmers likewise
tolerated the cats in exchange for free
pest control the relationship was so
Bennifer
show that the cats migrated with
Neolithic farmers from Anatolia into
Europe and the Mediterranean vermin were
a major scourge of the seven seas
they ate provisions and gnawed at lines
a rope so cats had long since become
essential sailing companions around the
same time these Anatolian globe-trotting
cats set sail
the Egyptians domesticated their own
local cats revered for their ability to
dispatch venomous snakes cat birds and
kill rats domestic cats became important
to Egyptian religious culture they
gained immortality in frescoes
hieroglyphs statues and even tombs
mummified alongside their owners
Egyptian ship cats cruised the Nile
holding poisonous river snakes at bay
and after graduating to larger vessels
they too began to migrate from port to
port during the time of the Roman Empire
ships traveling between India and Egypt
carried the lineage of the Central Asian
Wildcat FS or Nauta centuries later in
the Middle Ages Egyptian cats voyaged up
to the Baltic Sea on the ships of Viking
seafarers and both the Near Eastern and
North African Wildcats
probably tamed at this point continued
to travel across Europe eventually
setting sail for Australia and the
Americas today most house cats have
descended from either the Near Eastern
or the Egyptian lineage of f/s live
occur but close analysis of the genomes
and coat patterns of modern cats tells
us that unlike dogs which have undergone
centuries of selective breeding modern
cats are genetically very similar to
ancient cat and apart from making them
more social and docile we've done little
to alter their natural behaviors in
other words cats today are more or less
as they've always been wild animals
fierce hunters creatures that don't see
us as their keepers and given our long
history together they might not be wrong
if you love cats as much as we do
check out these lessons for more fun
facts on our feline friends
[Music]